[Music]
the 62nd Grammy Awards were filled with
epic performances including Ariana
Grande's show-stopping medley that did
not disappoint the 26 year old kicked
things off with imagine before
transitioning into my favorite things
[Music]
then it was time for a costume change
the singer training her black ball gown
for a sultry feathery ensemble which she
wore while singing seven rings from Abed
oh yeah she even did the splits and
Ariana appeared to be holding back tears
while performing her final song thank
you next
arjan amazing performance how was it
next album of the year winner Billie
Eilish delivered a haunting rendition of
win the party's over
the 18 year old ditching her usual dark
electronic backing to perform the ballad
with her brother Phineas on the piano
and a choir overall it was a huge night
for Billy who swept the big four Grammy
Awards Billy crazy night how do you how
do you take in this mom oh you don't say
youngest person ever to hit those awards
[Applause]
and Latin sensation Rosalia brought the
heat with a little flamenco flavor the
26 year old rocked a white ensemble with
cut outs and fringe during her dynamic
performance which came complete with
pyrotechnics
[Music]
the singer spoke with et backstage
moments after her electrifying
performance it had a lot of energy right
yes it's a great stage we offer amazing
speeds were going everywhere did you
notice they were lying there was like
okay okay I have to keep going keep
going but it's a big moment yes it is
move I'm saying narrow down
[Music]